is a class-based speciation something to
be concerned about
I'm elaborate on that a little bit what
do you mean exactly
or by class-based speciation meaning
there's already a tremendous amount of
wealth that is accumulated within such a
small percentage of people and whether
it be through a bifurcation of split of
a couple billion people off of the human
species or it could be a trifurcation we
don't know how many splits there may be
whether that I don't know if it's
something to worry about or something to
hope for
I mean this time scales are so large
that it's probably not relevant to
individuals potentially something to
hope for
in the evolutionary trajectory of the
Himba you kind of hope that people get
smarter might might get smarter across
time I guess we would hope that might be
a good thing I mean it's not
self-evident so if it is a lottery if it
was a roll of the dice to be born where
we are don't we also feel that it could
have been a roll of the dice to be born
in a place less fortunate there for sure
would you feel that I think that's why
you know even if you're successful
people often feel guilty because of
inequality if they know when were your
ultimate calling in terms of the width
of religion and with with finding
self-actualization and meaning within
you as to like you say eradicate
suffering is something that is give so
much meaning to life while the sometimes
people in less fortunate circumstances
experience lots of suffering with lack
of food or water or shelter or basic
geological needs and so then therefore
doesn't it feel like within this
potential class-based speciation with
wealth that there should be some sort of
assistant course oversight okay and now
that's the basis well so there's a
couple of things there I mean to the
degree like you know I've been a vocal
opponent of the radical left and I I
can't detest them enough really is this
a fundamental is the fun of my
fundamental position but
[Music]
but that doesn't mean that I don't think
that a functioning polity requires a
left in a right-wing absolutely and the
reason it requires a left wing is
because inequality is real and it has to
be addressed it has to be addressed for
all the reasons that you described but
but that having said that there are ways
to go about addressing it
that are clearly counterproductive and
those were tried to great destructive
power in the 20th century and I don't
really think we need to do that again
the corollary to that is we don't know
what the productive means are now I've
been thinking a lot about that you know
and I'm thinking well how do you solve
the problem of inequality and it has to
be something like the moral burden on
those who are successful has to be
increased it's something like that and I
think you see that I mean I think I
wrote this to you that what's the
significance of purchasing a third yacht
rather than maybe hiring 50 people to
solve a problem it's it's hard these
things aren't so simple you know like
let's say that you decide to go out to a
restaurant and your meal is five hundred
dollars and you might think well that's
reprehensible and well perhaps you don't
think that's reprehensible but the thing
is it's not a bad way of dispersing
extra money so it's not that obvious
what rich people should do with their
money that's beneficial and you think
well should you buy a third yard because
do you really need it and well that's a
particularly perhaps a particularly
egregious example but it's not like
you're not employing people when you do
that you shouldn't stuff the money in
your mattress we could say that right
because that's just pure hoarding but
most people who have money aren't like
Scrooge McDuck they don't have a money
bin that they swim in right their money
well that's that's the kind of that's
the kind of clueless picture of wealth I
mean most people who have money their
money is out there doing things it's not
like they're it's not like it's in their
bedroom you know it's in in gold coin
form so they're not hoarding it in
exactly the same way that perhaps people
used to hoard wealth when it wasn't as
what was tracked it and and and
functional in its own terms out there in
the economy is usually working for them
making them more money yeah but it's
also doing a bunch of other things you
know and if you're a bad money manager
even if you're wealthy your money tends
to disappear very rapidly that's another
thing that's really worth knowing is
that like there is a 1% and that 1% does
have a disproportionate amount of the
money and 1% of that 1% has an even more
disproportionate amount of the money it
scales all the way up the up the
measurement spectrum let's say but
there's actually quite a bit of mobility
within that 1% so you have a 10%
chance in your lifetime in the United
States of being in the top 1% for at
least a year now that's not like a
hundred percent chance but it's 1 in 10
it's not dismal you know so partly what
you hope for is that there's some
genuine upward mobility but then I think
the other thing that you hope for is
that people who are disproportionately
successful take it upon themselves to do
everything they possibly can to do
whatever they can that's the best
possible thing to do with their money
and you know I'm kind of an admirer of
Bill Gates for a variety of reasons but
he's doing a really good job of putting
the boots to the five world the world's
5 worst transmissible diseases you know
and that's going quite nicely you know
they're making some real polios just
about defunct they're making some real
progress with malaria like there's
almost nothing that could possibly be
done for Africa that would be more
useful than to get rid of malaria
sleeping sickness would be another one
that would be really useful to elect to
eradicate and so I would say that the
long-term solution assuming that there
is one to the problem of inequality is
that people who are disproportionately
fortunate let's say or successful or
both take it upon take the moral duty of
doing the best possible good that they
can with the money that they generate
great but the other thing I think that's
sort of interesting about that is I
actually don't think there's anything
more interesting to do with your money
that worked it's like can you think of
anything more interesting to do with
your money than to find a really
difficult problem that causes a bunch of
people suffering and then try to fix it
it's like amazing if you have a clue
that's got to be a little better than a
third yacht yeah so you know it's pretty
low well it's kind of a low like that
conspicuous consumption thing at some
point it's just if you have any sense
at some point that's just not